and also I think a very interesting
speakers dr. Amy shamaton she medical
information officer chief medical
informatics officer also
she's board-certified in internal
medicine and in clinical informatics her
med school is from here at OHSU her
residency is from legacy she's also a
double that she told me and so she is as
local as it gets
and John Kenickie dr. Hagee is is senior
vice president and CIO of legacy you are
so good the c-suite you can't get that
is wrong and also you know he's well
known to us because he's faculty here at
demise and many of you have actually
taken his excellent business informatics
course which is awesome thank you
1997 and then he's an engineer training
masters of Health Administration and Joe
Nash was on my dissertation committee
and John has actually been at OHSU
before anetha VA and at Providence so
comes to legacy with an extraordinary
perspective on both healthcare as well
as this is a clinical informatics Grand
Rounds and therefore it is eligible for
one hour of a MapR a category one credit
and if you're a physician and you wish
to avail of this after at any time email
Lynch Wahby at SC h p WB SCH wabe l at
OHSU dot edu and for those of you who
are outside
if you tweet the app OHSU informatics
with the hashtag team icon we can take
your questions if you have any at the
end of the talk and so with that
long-winded introduction welcome and I
will see for the floor so welcome to OHS
use water birthing class is not we're
gonna be talking about it and everyone
on the audio audience just didn't get
that joke but there was a sign when we
walked in water birthing class
so I'm John Koenig yzma thank you very
much dude for having us for having both
Amy and me here we're gonna talk about
EMR adoption model and the journey that
organizations take in a EMR adoption but
I'll start with a little bit about us
thank you for mentioning we added this
picture Silverton health down in
Silverton is the rural health system
that just joined our family officially
yesterday June first was our kickoff we
have two hospitals very large system but
we're locally and we've had a long a.m.
our journey we are on Epic we started
the epic journey around 2008 in
conceptual basis I was here CIO for the
Center for Health and healing and then
turned over to the hospital and I from
that conversation from that interaction
with epic just became a epic true
believer you sort of join a cult when
you work with that back they are an
amazing company but what we want to talk
about here is accreditation and this EMR
adoption model so hims just
definitions to start we'll use the
acronyms a lot hymns is the professional
Society for health IT practitioners it
has both vendors and practitioners like
us
it is the healthcare information and
management system Society and a number
of years ago we'll talk about the
history they adopted this model called
the MRAM or EMR before EHR was or her if
Microsoft resells fell checks your adopt
your acronym EMR adoption model is what
I wanted to start with this is the
audience participation
what designations or accreditation are
you familiar with that hospitals seek
you probably have badges on or big
banners on oh it's just you hospital or
Doernbecher hospital and you call out
any you know Jayco the Joint Commission
there are lots of them there are lots of
them around that are awards and
designations the hospital will go for
MRAM is one of them legacy has a number
of these and so just to set the stage
for sort of these the idea of having
external accreditation come in and look
at your standards obviously the College
of American Pathologists
you're running an accredited lab you
need to have a survey as we mentioned
the Joint Commission drink Commission
also has centers of excellence so do a
lot of health professional societies and
professional organizations so not to be
outdone the hims professional Society or
healthcare IT adopted this model for for
for health care and let me turn it over
to Amy who talks about what stage 7 the
highest 8 means
so I think the slide says it all what
are you lunch now
so just again a little bit of background
so as many of you know hims is a
nonprofit organization whose goal is to
promote the best of information
technology and management systems in the
healthcare industry and their vision is
really around improving health for the
better use of technology and information
and so they have created this adoption
model for the EMR the purpose of which
is to ensure that the most relevant
clinical information is available to the
clinical decision maker at the right
place and at the right time so they
created this model for the acute care
setting in 2005 and it really reflects a
typical manner in which a hospital
system might progress toward a paperless
system and introduces the concept of
this roadmap they subsequently developed
an ambulatory model in 2010 and now they
have a continuity of care model which
they developed in 2013 so it's a
progressively sophisticated model
starting with those systems that may be
lab but not pharmacy or maybe radiology
and lab but not pharmacy or whatever and
progressively gets more sophisticated
now interestingly this is not a static
designation so when we validated for
stage 7 in 2013 we met all the criteria
obviously we became stage 7 we are now
looking at revalidating which you do
every three years and new things have
come along so blood product
administration module or blood bank
matching is new so that's something that
we have to raise our standard tune in
order to meet stage 7 at this time
breast milk scanning and another one
that
between our validations was the our code
medication administration in the IDI as
well as everywhere else so there's and
then the other piece of this is that in
20 in January 2017 hims is looking at
releasing essentially different criteria
for all these stages so progressing the
model forward and I believe stage zero
essentially does way so state zero will
then be the ancillary lab radiology and
pharmacy all installed will now be stage
zero so not all the stages come down
like one step but they're there making
the model more sophisticated just where
do you think American healthcare data
repository data from their from their
documentation stage but the biggest part
of validating for stage tell your story
they can actually use the data that
you're collecting in your system
that no clinical data that's important
sit on in a scanning basket for more
than 24 hours and then other that's the
benchmark is the vitals are integrated
in nice use to show interoperability so
caribou wear is great if you pair
everywhere is only exchanging with other
epic systems that doesn't count for this
for stage seven you actually have to
exchange with a non epic system at least
one and and that bar will go up as well
I'm sure all medications in epic even if
you have to show that that that
information gets put into the record at
some point in time so it's important
that you can then look at the full
patient record and see what medications
were administered through their Hospital
course you have to show that you're
using you don't have a culture of
doctors walking by and giving verbal
orders that would never happen right Jim
every electronic repackaging variation
95% on barcode medication administration
and what this means is that they at
least tried to scan the medication in
the patient ninety-five percent of the
time it doesn't have to be successful
because you know for multiple reasons
barcode medication administration
scanning is if the label gets a little
upset with a little bend
or something they don't scan very well
and then as I mentioned earlier the
breast milk and blood scanning for
ambulatory stage one is access to
clinical information stage two again the
clinical data repository stage three
clinical documentation support and
basket functionality Stage four again
CPOE with a prescribing as an as a at
least being available and then Stage
five as much around that patient health
record and what we would call my chart
Stage six includes some best practice
advisories and health maintenance
modifiers and patient reminders so
reminding patients to come in for their
health maintenance such as colonoscopy
and then stage seven interoperability
did analytics with the tools in epic
parlance cooperative's care scenarios
care everywhere exchanges as we
discussed in the inpatient realm and
then more than 95 percent CPOE for
ambulatory so why profile with a stage
seven organization is to use data to
drive improved outcomes related to
process ease financial clinical quality
and safety and it's essentially so
getting to dogs question the majority of
hospitals are at Stage five with many
moving toward Stage six and stage seven
and then you can see on the ambulatory
side the majority is actually down in
stage one and two forward it's still a
couple things one one of the things that
would that surprised me is still
two-person
the hospital 2% of six thousand
hospitals remain without lab radiology
and pharmacy all three of them I mean
just have those which have been around
since the to get to get to stage one you
have all three of those
when hims got involved with the incoming
Obama administration eight years seven
years ago when we were putting together
the work on ARRA the American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act which provided the
funding or meaningful use of certified
electronic health records so folks from
the incoming administration called hims
to say you know we want to invest money
and we'd like to get eletronic health
records across the board and certainly
get CPOE and closing the bar code
medication administration but you get to
the stage for where you have physician
documentation and pharmacy online and
what that would cost
and so that's worth a twenty billion
dollars from we use the goal was to get
every US hospital to stage for the life
of the HITECH Act and there's still
about twenty percent more than 30
percent more than forty percent I mean
so Stage six and seven across the u.s.
is at what just over thirty percent okay
verdict sis stage seven but if you
include Stage six so 30 hospitals
there's sixty five hospitals and
Oregon's that were
so pretty good adoption in the state of
Oregon those five hospitals four of them
are legacy is one of them is Kaiser
oh it just you is not Steven so I
thought it was pretty cool so this shows
how long it takes to dig make national
progress so over the course of nine
years we've taken the majority of
hospitals have gone from stage one and
two five and six
pretty impressive adoption rate over
over time particular stage I went
hospitals kind of get stuck where yeah I
think it's a great question I think CPOE
to get to stage seven of ninety 90
percent CPOE is hard I think that's a
that's a that's a real
this is an order entry I think is a real
high Bertil high or a high hurdle to it
yet I I think that the for us at legacy
and here I think here the I would have
talked to John done a lot about sort of
our journey and I think OHSU is state is
state six the scanning so the amount of
paper like in the behavioral health
units barcode administration medication
administration in behavioral health and
there's sort of the amount of paper you
really to get from six to seven is
really sort of no clinical paper
generated that is a that is a very high
bar how are those is it the data is that
the right data views your denominator
the number of hospitals are a number of
hospital beds because again if you have
twenty hospitals that have 30 beds each
and that's only three percent of the
hospital beds in the state I think it's
a much different
I think you're right certainly academic
medical centers have historically been
high on adoption of IT large systems
epic systems which of course epic cells
generally to the large and then it's us
who have to host for a smaller but I
think you're right in terms of us beds I
bet that percentage would be a lot
higher I'm just gonna say though I'm not
sure it depends what you what you're
looking for because the hospitals might
be a better representation of patient
access to you know a high stage Hospital
care right I mean yes they might only
have a few beds in some rural place but
that's there's that whole community I
think there's a huge barrier of course
of cost so for legacies journey was
about a hundred million dollars of
capital and another hundred million in
the operating so about a the budget for
epic was about a hundred and twelve
million we finished around 93 million so
we came in under budget but that for us
the meaningful use dollars represented
about forty million dollars so it's
really and that was my experience at
Providence and I left here before we got
meaningful yoose dollars in but roughly
I've heard that average that about forty
percent of your costs in EMR
implementation will be covered by
federal grants through Medicaid and
Medicare through the meaningful use
program but you have to come up with the
sixty percent and that's that's a lot at
Providence our investment was just over
just north of 1 billion dollars
yes yes the 40% is not given to you
upfront its recovery a couple years
later maybe I think it's the other thing
for for ambulatory is the doctors
offices that have to you know adopt and
now with Macra I mean they're more for
private physicians in private practice
EMR adoption is is a high bar we host
for a number of physicians it's a $5,000
upfront cost
it was $15,000 and we're reducing that
as we donate through a program that
legacy offers are witches who doesn't
offer that positions but there's just a
high hurdle the other thing I think that
it's a hurdle is stages of EMR so epic
was our third EMR at Silverton which
will go on epic in about 11 months they
have five current EMRs we're just
talking to st. Charles and Bend both
OHSU and legacy have been friendly you
know brethren to the st. Charles
facility and they're there they have
decided to go epic epic will be their
fourth EMR in the last seven years so
it's just it's so highly disruptive I
think people are scared of it and it's a
lot of money and a lot of organizational
risk but done right it can mean a good
difference a journey to China
there-there adoption is coming along and
they're very interested in this model
internationally now as a benchmark so
it'll be interesting changes over the
next year so the road to stage 7 so to
do stage 0 to 5 is really a online
self-assessment so it's you answering
questions about your system and
organization and it places you
essentially in a in a certain stage when
you get to stage 6 you continue to do
that online assessment and then you
apply to essentially have a verification
call we
you get questioned pretty
comprehensively about your system and
such and then either do or don't get
awarded stage 6
for stage 7 it's those first two it's
the online self-assessment
it's a online or it's a telephone call
and then you have your criteria you then
have an on-site visit with three
reviewers including the hims
representative an active CIO and an
active CMIO
from other systems so it's it's a it's a
it's it's a reasonably rigorous day of
system I'm more sedentary but both Amy
and I are hims seven evaluators yeah
yeah oh thanks so this is just an
example of the day of the visit so you
actually spend the majority of the
morning sharing your story including how
you've used your data and analytics to
improve care and to improve your
business operations so that's actually
quite in my presence it's actually quite
a fun piece of this because it actually
celebrates the work that you and the
team have done over time and when you go
back and look at how much you've
accomplished it's just it's actually
really great for the group you then
start doing floor visits and the the
group of three goes on to the units and
starts looking around for paper and
starts asking questions and I'll tell
some more stories about that later in
the presentation they do take a good
look at your medical records department
because there's a lot to find in there
the emergency department you go to
pharmacy radiology you actually go to
lab I miss that on here apologize and
then the reviewers go off into a
secluded room and make their decision as
to whether you have successfully
achieved the criteria for stage seven
yeah what's the success rate when you
get somebody to come out and do that I
mean today it's it's reasonably high but
because they do that that pre-call to
make sure that you're actually on track
but I can tell you that some of the
visits that I've been on it
the team has been running around because
they haven't really made their case in
that first presentation as to how
they're actually using data it's really
interesting how hard that is for some
teams to relay even I mean they have
scads of data and they're doing all
sorts of stuff but actually to really
present that and show how it is
affecting patient outcomes or or
business outcomes or whatever you know
they're they're trying to prove it's
actually harder than then one might
think and so I've actually I've done two
were pretty but the team was like as
you're as you're going around and and
you're on the wards and looking at stuff
if you've told them after their
presentation that you didn't quite get
this piece or one of them was actually
with with ours it was actually coming up
with a story around our disaster
recovery because our servers our backup
servers are in the same geographic
location they're in stains if code
barely blocks away and and that was an
issue for the reviewers and so coming up
with what our strategy is to deal with
that and where we will be so I did the
multi care review multi care is the
system sort of like legacy in Tacoma and
they were only evaluating one hospital
to be stage seven and it was sort of
their their lower acute not their their
main hospital and what we found was
there were there was paper which is okay
paid clinical relevant paper generated
and they had h-i-m come through and
every day twice a day would go through
the hospital and bring it down to
central scanning and put it into epic
but they didn't do that route they
didn't do that run on Saturdays and son
and and the requirement is that anything
that's clinically relevant this paper is
in online within 24 hours and so we gave
them we didn't pass them but we said if
you certify and then we had one of our
reviewers go back to confirm but if you
actually just start that means I am
going around Saturdays and Sundays we
would mean it was it's a rigorous but I
would echo Amy's point that there's so
much organization doesn't have to pay
for it in downloading a sport except the
recertification the organisation has to
do so Tim's is putting a lot they pay
our travel and expenses to go to the
safe zone it's a fairly extensive a lot
of money to pay so they want to make
sure you're really ready before you do
the on-site evaluation so what is the
motivation for the hospital to go
through this rigorous process what do
they get in the end for it you were
here's my slide than the next one of the
things that I think that is important is
that it is a national benchmark so it's
you can guide yourselves against against
something that says basically on a
journey for electronic health record we
it's one of the things that I struggled
with and coming back and presenting it's
plaque that goes in the lobby of all of
our hospitals really beautiful and I
think paperless and I said I know
speaking to you all physicians it's hard
for me to you know I recognize this is a
journey and we need to continue to
improve usability and the flow and the
design electronic health records still
are in their infancy there's a huge
dependency of course on them but but
having a benchmark I think is wonderful
it is an externally validated measure of
excellence so your achievement I think
there's this other one the recognition
and
operation of incredibly hard work to
really get to that point requires
clinician leadership technology you know
this is amalgamation of a lot of people
working really hard and the higher end
Ram designation and the seven-step stage
seven has led and led to us as well at
legacy hi better bond ratings and lower
malpractice insurance because it is
externally validated so the next slide
is our attempt because we're unhappy
there's the hospital health care most
wired so this is self-report only there
is no validation and so I've tended to
call the most liar because if you are
sort of extrapolate
stretching the truth on how fabulous you
are in an electronic health record the
year that we received the state seven
across all of our hospitals and amatory
clinics the first organization to get
both we did not get the most wired okay
there's something odd about it but let
me continue to go on in terms of what
have studies now they're still coming
out with this correlate stage seven
hospital with better quality lower
mortality better profitability and this
is what this site so in terms of Joan
your question of why would you do it
first of all there's why would you want
to achieve the paperless and I think
that is the goal for us our hundred
million dollar investment was moving
towards healthcare that is driven by
better information and better technology
and that is translated to organizations
around quality so this is the Joint
Commission of the Joint Commission's
quality measure performance and there
are a number of measures with three or
less or four or more of the measures met
and you can see that there is a
correlation not a causation potentially
and so you know maybe higher performing
hospitals also have a lot of other
things I don't it's not a causal but
it's correlated that that
higher higher stage hospitals perform
better on the quality measures for the
Joint Commission another statistic is
the Leapfrog Group so leapfrog is a
Association or an organization and so
representative hospital is an a leapfrog
hospital safety grade and we're measure
of having this score in the value-based
purchasing and sort of where the
organization is the sort of middle level
performance when you are there's a
higher mortality rates driven by health
grade mortality in a lower MRAM score
versus higher and then finally
profitability financial performance this
was measured remember the source of this
one now but in terms of higher
profitability the operating margin for
organizations has appeared to be higher
for organizations that are in state
seven the question of causation versus
correlation on these I think that
because there's a little bit more
discussion maybe and particularly this
one where you know higher performing
organizations financially may just
the money money today implementation
could be the other way around
yes and then you know the other ones it
may just be a surrogate marker of high
reliability organizations in general yes
yes there was a study one of our
doctoral I think he finished the
doctor'll one of our first doctor
students was his name anyway doesn't
matter he was one of the when D mice
started the doctorate program he was one
of our first students and he attempted
to do Adam thank you Adam worked on our
research on looking at stage six and
seven versus quality measures and
external measures and and my point after
and it was not found there was it was
not found to no correlation between six
and seven hospitals and quality and all
these other measures of success my point
to that is six is a fairly low bar so if
you have CPOE in just the IDI you can
get Stage six seven is CPOE everywhere
ninety percent adoption so I think
safety the the higher bar of seven even
though there are fewer hospitals I think
is six is just too necessarily and he
didn't find six and seven hospitals
we're not necessarily better quality for
years ago and EMR use you know it takes
time to become really facile in using it
and have the implications and develop
the data to be able to run quality
surveys and you know really promote
quality so I think you I think you're
very much right on at that point well
the other thing I'd say too is that a
lot of the quality and process measures
are captured of a system that's designed
to capture the data irrespective of
whether the data are accurate or not
mm-hm so for example there's been plenty
of studies for example which show that
everybody regardless of what smoking
cessation they got all right
not callously they got have the box
checked on admission so if you have an
order set that's put it as part of stage
seven that has an automatic pre checked
box you're processing quality measures
will go up dramatically but that does
not let say represent outcome outcomes
and you know the best example that were
CLABSI rates in the United States where
as soon as it became part of meaningful
use the incidence and prevalence of
class C's dropped by 90 percent in three
months after ten years of stability so
again realizing that when systems are
designed to improve reporting of
measures that then are used to determine
the effectiveness of the system it is a
self-fulfilling prophecy in many ways
that's a really good point still want
the amount I remember the in in getting
our doing our our survey and the point
about you know how often is it sort of
touch-and-go and I wasn't in the room
were you in the room when they did the
they were in imaging they did this the
survey so that you know the surveyors
are going in and talking and one of the
radiologists says I'm glad you're here I
hate that back I let me just tell you
what I just don't like about this needs
to change this needs to change our packs
integrated and and the and our people
that are accompanying are like just oh
god he just blew just you know there we
go we're not going to be stage seven and
and the surveyor said well do you use it
it's like well of course I can't do
clinical care without it okay but yes it
needs to be improved but it's not it's
that you're still using the system so as
I said Amy and I are both we have been
independent CIO CMIO evaluations and so
I've had the pleasure of looking at a
number of sites in this order Stanford
Hospital UCLA Cedar sinai and multi care
up in Tacoma which is there were all
really interesting interesting they were
all epic all of them epic but not all
not all epic of course is stage seven
and not all stage seven is epic meant
there are
not too many but there are some meta
tech state 7 and I think Cerner has a
few as well but really good good
programs but that about the week or
maybe a right around the time that I was
invited to go to Tacoma then they called
a me and said would you go to China
okay I'm gonna try that you go to Tacoma
Chang shinyang China which is kind of
near the North Korean border to do both
hospital and impatient and it was
amazing what they have done I'll show
you these are a couple of the nurses I'm
at and wanted so it's just an important
I was just going to tell a couple
stories about some of our reviews but
one of the things is preparing your
staff and we thought we had prepared our
staff quite well and we even you know
you can choose a little bit of who's
around or which radiology department you
go to or whatever I mean right that
didn't work so well but I wanted the
wards in at Good Samaritan Hospital we
went up there and the reviewers are
going around and they're asking about
asking I think was an LPN actually what
do you do in downtime and she said well
I go in and I tidy up the patient's room
and I make sure that they have anything
that they want though their water you
know pick up the newspapers and they're
like no you know when when when it when
the computers down and you can't like oh
I just go over to another computer and I
start taking our daytime staff had not
experienced a downtime and so long they
didn't even know what it was and so it
actually brought up process for us we
now actually are doing more downtime
training both in the evenings during the
days and what she's when she's not
active so hilarious
interestingly in Xianyang they have a
vendor
actually employs 20,000 people 20 of
which are on-site at this hospital
hospital is quite busy they see upwards
of a thousand patients in their IDI on a
daily basis that was a daily basis they
see tens of thousands of patients in
their clinics every day and in fact just
for comparison what's what's an
emergency department like OHS you see in
a year like right so things have to be
efficient and one of the things I was
most interested in as I spoke to some of
the specialists that we met with was how
many patients a day are the specialists
seeing and that range from fifty to a
hundred patients a day I can tell you
they are not held to the same
documentation standards as we are here
in the United States and but they are
putting good information in the chart I
mean it's very clinically relevant you
know shorthand whatever but they're
actually they are documenting and they
don't have to worry about what needs to
be in there for billing or such so fifty
to a hundred patients a day so they took
us to the outpatient clinic it's a big
tower of a building and you walk into
the building and there's hundreds of
people waiting to get on the elevators
to go upstairs and they walk us around
we were like this special group of felt
really weird but so this the revere
group gets walked around to a private
elevator and we go straight up he come
out on his floor it felt like an airport
there was Airport like airports eating
there were monitors everywhere to tell
patients who in the next patient up was
or the next couple patients so you could
kind of monitor the progress of that
provider who you were going to see there
were kiosks for the patients to make
appointments for them to print out their
prescription after their visits to or to
send their prescription
to the pharmacy if they chose to use the
pharmacy in that building they then
would get a text message on their phone
if they so indicated on the kiosk as to
when their medication was ready it was
amazing I mean the experience was truly
amazing their clinical rooms I have to
tell initials in the room but was
literally a desk a desk the doctor had
their computer and the front of the desk
was a stool there's a little sink in the
room you wash your hands and watch there
was a lot of medical equipment there
wasn't a lot of comfort if it was a in
the gynecologic clinic there was a
backroom to take the patient to that
they needed to do an exam but privacy
was not a high point I would have to say
interesting experience another journey
on in China that I think be interesting
is the one thing that they hadn't really
figured out was the disaster covered and
they didn't have they also their system
was up 97% of done very high 90s percent
of the time but the chief residents were
the ones that would back up that floors
data when they went home every night
they all had these thumb drives so they
would actually do the backup and that
would be so if the system went down at
any point in time they're the ones who
got all the information so I went to an
Obie Award and the word was made to hold
I have to get this right 30 patients no
20 patients which would have no there
are 20 rooms told 40 patients with two
beds in each room and they had put a
third bed in each room but there are 66
patients on the ward and so those
additional patients were actually on air
mattresses in the hallway that's how
busy they're there and they they were I
mean they're turning them through how
many patients did that chief resident
have everybody who was on that ward 66
patients wasn't clear to me how many
interns or
residents she had to assist her in that
in that journey but just that the sheer
volume of patients in this place was
something that we truly want understand
another interesting piece from that
visit was length of stay was much higher
than ours in the over ten range for many
different kinds of patients because the
clinic Doc's would actually admit
patients if they needed a surgical
procedure because the process of getting
the surgery approved and and dealt with
was much easier to put them in the
hospital have that patient actually wait
in the hospital to get the procedure
than actually to schedule that as an
outpatient so again a different system
and and they work around it as they can
oh just just because Doc's are seen 50
to 100 you know you ask you're like and
how do you do that and one of the pieces
was this is this is a big city where a
lot of people come for care from rural
areas and one of their one of one of the
docs said to me it was I don't know how
far that patient has come and I don't
know you know if they have any place to
stay from the night or I don't know what
their social circumstances are around
this visit so it's I always feel
obligated to see them so if there's
patients waiting they just continue to
see them because they don't know what
potentially difficulties the patient
would run into if they said no you need
to come back tomorrow this is a just a
screenshot of of their electronic health
record but the the piece being that they
actually had some pretty good crema to
show it but unless you wish Nate do you
read but they they were doing a lot of
structured documentation they had a lot
of shortcuts in in their documentation
to pull stuff up they were very careful
with how they did that interestingly
making sure that the record was accurate
this is to remind me of something I
learned from dr. Richard Gibson as I was
on a visit with him
Sutter Health and we went into the
medical records department and I don't
know how many of you know Gibson but
he's he's just a wonderful guy and he
starts like going through this stack of
things that need to be scanned and I'm
like what's he doing and he's looking
through an he pulls out like a physician
note and he's like what's this and
they're like and so the piece being that
the documentation it needs to be in the
electronic health record and even if you
scan it in if it's if it's done your
facility it really should be done in the
record and so he really taught me a lot
about during reviews and how to how to
look for four different pieces that that
people may or may not know about he was
telling me about a visit he did early in
his doing visits where he went into the
the the site said that they their
radiology was all digital they were sure
of it and then they go into the
radiology department and there's there's
one machine that's putting out films and
of course he finds it he's that kind of
guy so he was he was actually a really
good mentor for doing these visits
because of how detailed he is and then
this is the journey that we're actually
embarking on right now is his blood
product administration and and the
matching out to the blood bank
so we scan all of our blood products
currently but it doesn't match back out
to the blood bank which is an extra
patient safety piece that that we would
of course like to do we're struggling a
little bit because we have Cerner on our
on our lab side and epic on our clinical
side and we don't want we don't want
nursing to have to go into yet another
program which would be serve blood
product administration module to do it
and an epic ins aren't actually having
some trouble talking on this so our
journey to our revalidation is is is a
little stilted right now but do want to
talk about
I asked what would what does the
organization get out of it
and I think I've heard the same four
organizations that are looking for the
Baldrige criteria the value for us to
not only reflect on our journey but also
document what we had done was a great
internal it was a motivator for us it
was definitely a motivator to accomplish
some things that we wanted to accomplish
it was certainly ways we got a lot of
data to heightened we had a couple
hospitals that weren't meeting the bar
code medication and the CPOE percentages
that needed to be achieved and so got
the visibility and encouragement to get
that up which we do believe correlates
with safety and so I think we're we're
really good just going through the
process itself I think had positive
consequences for our organization I have
enjoyed going through the other places I
learn as you noted particularly I've
done just epic US visits but everyone
does epic a little bit differently and
and so some of the things that I saw
that we're really great have facilitated
cross communication between epic
customers and Cannavale that was an
interesting you know very novel approach
to it
can we talk more about it after the
visit and so the epic family is a very
close-knit family to begin with but
that's been a really neat part of doing
this silly question make it to a certain
stage do you ever get downgraded again
wait so how often is the revalidation or
the recertification every three years
and how much does it cost to get an
organization ready for each one of these
site visits so again is this you know
it's sort of like yo J Co was done by
hospitals for hospitals and ends up
basically again becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy so you know
what is the what's the optimal type
frame where the resources are required
so how much it's one thing for a
hospital to get ready how many hospitals
are going to continue to continue to do
this every three years
this bar this is what we need to do
we're done with this I think because
it's an evolving model it's why I
continue to be excited about
revalidating because it actually
continues to keep us at a certain level
as I say we're struggling right now to
do this we're in the throes of it trying
to revalidate in October it's it's great
for the team to I mean it's just one of
those things to work towards but as John
says I mean our team it just the
excitement around the is an informatics
team and and honestly the clinical teams
as well was so worth the journey how
much time we're we're it's part of our
directors meeting currently it's really
not that big of a deal we already had
the CPOE reports written the BCM a
reports written all those things that
you have to go back and make sure you're
still holding that standard and then as
you do the gap analysis I mean it didn't
take me very long to do the gap analysis
partly because I'm a reviewer so I kept
up on it but so there was the gap
analysis and then there's a couple
projects but some of which we I mean
we'd already done we don't attend the
breast mike scanning we'd already put
our code medication administration into
the IDI and so this is our this is our
nuts not our only hurdle we have so one
of the things that's occurred in a
couple of our ICUs is multidisciplinary
rounding and as a part of
multidisciplinary rounding I'm finding
because I looked at two units whose CPOE
is not where I would have expected it to
be and it actually has to do with
multidisciplinary rounding where a nurse
is putting in the orders for the day for
the intensivists that's not CPOE that's
a verbal order and so it's just tanked
orders on that unit so we're we're
working through some processes to see if
we can you know shine that up and and
and have the provider putting in the
actual orders and so I mean it it brings
up some spotlights some things that you
might not have gone back and looked at
again anyway I do think it's a really
good question though because the number
of hospitals in state seven are now is
growing and the revalidation
recertification is new as Amy said they
are continuing to evolve they don't want
to add a stage eight they talked about
it and it's more like know now how care
needs to continue to evolve and so we
have this bar set or what we think
excellence is about we're kind of
competitive at like you see and so we
want to slightly that we measure we
measure saw repec doesn't number of
benchmarks as well and how well you do
in in epic adopting they have 800 of
best practices and what percentage do
you have adopted and then the epics
stars is the name of their program so
we're we've pursued that as well and but
I think hospitals I think it will decide
whether you want to achieve it or not
fortunately what I think there as they
continue the bar higher like more
business intelligence and population
health it is where we're going and so
again having that external validation I
think is worthwhile dr. Burdick there
was some discussion a year or two back
and I haven't followed it since then
about eliminating the need to do both
meaningful use documentation or a de
stations and also the mram and and other
ones and just consolidating the state do
one or the other and you can get credit
for meaningful use dollars by getting to
mram stage seven or something like that
has there been further discussion about
trying to consolidate these I haven't
heard such discussions but I'd be
interested to ask names organization
about that because that would be they
were probably do it because it would
promote more doing that but I that whole
meaningful use we're audited so
frequently and so that all the things
you need to do for attestation I I sort
of can't believe that the government
would give that much authority to hims
analytics to measure your compliance
it's federal dollars and it'd be great
the whole measurement industrial complex
you know every group is the pqrs I mean
they're just we're having to slice and
dice data the measures that we give to
Oregon Medicaid are different than we
give to Medicare it's just as it's
insane from a bi perspective and
reporting perspective it'd be great if
we could narrow she said yeah Don
Berwick just in his most recent speeches
was arguing that point that we're
actually decreasing quality in health
care because of an overemphasis on
measurement and the measurement process
and the industrial complex around
measurement in health care well your
point about order sets that have it auto
checked whether you really do it or not
there's a lot where I think the reality
is is that as long as there's carrots or
sticks people will do whatever they can
to avoid the stick and eat the carrot
even if they don't like vegetables and
so electronic tools actually make it
easier to you for you to show what
you're doing because no longer can
ignorance be considered or the prop for
pretend point rights no longer is like
well we don't have a way to document it
that's automatically considered a
negative women before was considered an
indeterminant we've talked about state 7
and its meaning to organizations to even
to clinicians to my question is really
do you guys have a sense of whether this
is a measure that patients understand
and what you know what from from
legacies perspective know how have you
tried to market the idea of him so 872
patients and what kind of responses
you've had
it's a great question and we took when
we got the designation we talked to our
marketing people about do you want how
do we want to you know do the press
release so hims comes out with a press
release that they release and then it's
sort of the trade magazines pick it up
but sort of what do we want to do with
their or Gonia nor anything that
particularly being the first in the
world or in the country to have EMR
stage seven across ambulatory and
Clinics of Kaiser doesn't have that and
so there's a point of local pride in
Oregon for this and our marketing people
I think very rightly we you know they
talked to a couple of story a couple of
reporters who were like I don't
understand what the public interest in
this would be so you know they're there
to sell papers of course and so you know
could you put me in touch with a patient
whose experience was positive because of
this technology or you know and your
point I think there isn't